you
[Music]
mmm hi everyone I'm very happy to
introduce we went from university to
give us his research presentation on
efficient and scalable deep learning and
so many of us are working on deep
learning or in the area of related to
deep learning right especially nowadays
we we love to training large models that
had a burden DBT but here way is going
to share a very unique perspective of
deep learning where he focused on the
efficiency of deep learning and in
particular in particular he focused our
model compression and deep dish pizza
training and and autumn L in we also
help reach industry experience he
interned the ways Ana's are here and
integrate Google Google brain and the
Facebook AI and now let's learn that way
thank you saying that hi everyone I'm
away from Chuck thanks for coming really
glad to be here since I did like to
internship here and I'm trying to get
myself upgraded so topic today is about
the efficient and scalable deep learning
and beyond
so the general the general kind of deep
learning is we can always get a better
performance if we are able to train a
larger models given we have a lot of
data so here is a figure which covers
the majority of the computer vision
models and the x-axis is the computation
cost y-axis is the accuracy so in
general in general if we compute a logic
model we can always get a better
performance
this is typically true for one specific
neural architectures for example for
ResNet we can get a better performance
if we can get a deeper new networks and
this is similar for like inception model
and similarly in natural language
processing we also get a similar change
so if we can hear you the example for
language modeling
and on wikitext so if we can build a
larger model we can get a better
perplexity so we are still curious about
how can we go below if we can still do
the larger models in NLP problems so the
question is why don't we always build a
larger model but there are their
obstacles the first obstacle is on a
training site since training larger
model is very slow so if we have a new
model we want to evaluate so we want to
check is this new model is a good or not
then we will take a longer training time
to get the feedback so usually we have
to evaluate a lot of model before we
find a good model so this one what if we
model is too large the what extend our
research cycle and production cycle the
second obstacle is on the infant's Park
so after we peel the model eventually we
want to use it so but if the model is
too large the inference time is very
slow so it will be very challenging to
deploy those models to applications
which have very limited computing
resources or memory resources like in
microsoft hololens so my research in
general is trying to make the train in
faster and also influenced faster so we
can build a larger model and also to
make those model and deliver deliverable
to like applications in real industry
productions so here is outline offers to
introduce my previous research to make
the trina-- faster typically in
distributed training systems and also my
research on spas new networks to make
the inference faster and the felony our
introduced my future research so let's
go to the first part how can we make the
distributed training system faster so
I'll focus on one work I did on Canary
gradients to reduce the communication in
these people
learn so here here's a little bit
background about distributed learning so
in synchronized SGD we have a cinder
parameter server and we first split we
are we sent the parameter to multiple
machines and trained those model in
parallel but using different data after
the training is done at each machine
will synchronize the gradients to the
sender primary server and that this
finishes one run one iteration though it
will keep doing this again and again
this is a good because we are a lot of
machine which means we can trim faster
but we have problem we have the
communication bottleneck problem so so
in general if we have more machine then
we can always reduce our computation
time but since we have more machine
which means we have more synchronization
over the network
so the communication turn will increase
so your total time war was saturate at a
some point so you cannot go beyond one
point so it limit this cable scalability
of distributed
tip learning system so my research goal
is trying to reduce the communication
time and make our disability training
more scalable so that's simple
so in distributed training system we can
slightly change the community
communication pattern that we only
communicate gradients over the network
so each worker brought compute the
gradients and send over the sender
parameter which was a verbal to the
gradients at the sent back so we only
communicate gradients over the network
so you journey gradients are floating
precision which have 32 bits per element
on location so notation here W is the
weight and G is a gradient and so at
each Walker it will first compute
gradient on each data so it was sent
back sent to the parameter server and it
will average all the gradients from all
the Walker and the kid they averaged a
gradient and send back then each Walker
will be updated by the average gradient
in coffees yes yes all the models are
always the same
yes by the same we yes yes so the
initialization is the same so so the
updates is also the same so it will
always be the same as along it as long
as we use the same issue the trend a yes
Moore is in the locker and they use the
same initialization seat
so there will be always the same this
way we can only communicate the
gradients and what our is explaining why
it's beneficial to only communicate
gradients over the network
so you generates 32 in this work we do
our conversation we reduce the precision
to only three three levels so only three
discrete values we call this ternary
gradients and tranquil in short if we
can successfully two days we can reduce
at least 16 times of reduction of the
communication so this will be very
challenging because it will lose lot of
precision in the training process
even of this weight yes yeah I'm real
bad yes yes so the basic idea is simple
so and before I go to the detail let's
go one step back so when we do this
really training in the sutras learning
in general we want to minimize the
averaged lost over all the training
samples and the gradients can be updated
by the gradient from all the data set
and Ernie's usually very large so the
computation is very costly so in deep
learning usually we use a stochastic
version we sample we random samples from
the data set and we use the sample
gradients to estimate the original batch
gradient it works well because one
reason is the expectation the
expectation of the gradients is the
original batch gradient so it's it's
it's own biased so if so why don't we do
an conversation in a way such that after
the conversation we still keep the
expectation so here the motivation is we
do our generalization on the floating
gradient and we want to keep the
expectation is as an original gradient
so it's a still unbiased gradient so
that that's the motivation so how can we
do it it's it's simple actually so this
one is the floating gradient and we
first get the sum of all the gradients
and then we have a scalar which is small
usually very small
[Music]
um it is either lot learned easy so st
is the maximum absolute value of the
order gradients so okay so we have those
two part and then a two element wise
multiplication where is a binary binary
code which is either 1 or 0 and but this
one this one is the random random
variable so it's it's basically
Bernoulli distribution the probability
for each element its probability of
being 1 is just the absolute value of
the gradients over the maximum scalar
here K is the case the index of the the
gradients so yeah we have K gradients
they just coordinate so the index oh so
so GG is all the gradients and they'd
have element wise multiplied by a vector
so K is the index of the vector which is
a binary binary code like here so so
let's go to the example so let's say an
hour floating gradient is like this
value and we get the maximal absolute
value which is 1.2 and then we get the
Sun of all the gradients then we form
our the lowly distribution and the it's
probability of P 1 so let's say for this
element it's probability of B 1 is just
0.3 over 1 point you so it's simple and
then we draw a blue T distribution from
this probability we get there sample of
the binary code and we multiply all of
them so if you do in this way we do a
little bit of math here so the
expectation of the quantizer the
gradients is just the expectation of the
original one so its own biased so we
keep the expectation
but we do increase a little bit variance
but I'll go for more detail about how we
reduce the variance so then we only need
like two bits for each element and the
one single floating value so it works
significant in the reduced a on
communication volley for example why do
we need a 50
why do we need Pete he is we want to
draw we want a jaw we want to draw a
really description because and so first
they they devalue the eventually the
value is just 1 or 0 so it's binary so
the precision we can regain so the only
three values three possible values here
then we can encode it in a very low
procedure and zero minus a a minus T and
s T so there is a scale a small scalar
here from this to that
so here we have expectation over 2 and
then we can expectation over Z and the
expectation over peak even see the
others so this one have low low value be
lately 2 Z so it's gone yes then this
one is just a P so we get yeah ok so
about how is the expected value of B
equal to XL value of gee I don't follow
this one yeah so how do you exactly I
just want to see her over your
simplification here how do you simplify
this your mobility the technical
probability yes just there the
probability just gtk over s team yes it
expected oh you just kept eating
yes he k originally taking that yeah
yeah it's it's a testicle light variable
stuff so didn't talk detail but it's
just a production so let's say what's
the day it's just a date data so we only
care about Petey
so the BT is expectation BD is just the
probability a probability which is this
one and they multiply this one with this
one it will reduce to that one okay we
prove the convergence of two in grant
and this one is the basic assumption to
prove the convergence of standard STD
and so it's standard it's not ours so to
prove the convergence of ten grant we do
need a little bit of stronger assumption
on the gradient bound here so in the
standard STD the lq should be bounded
but now we require the multiplication
between the maximum load and l1 not
bound it
so this value is always larger than this
value so 10 grand
do you need a little bit stronger bound
but but we we proposed some tricks to
make those two pounds closer to each
other so one is a layer wise
generalization we do it layer wise me
because differently you have different
distribution and we also are to create
and clipping to limit the range of the
gradients but tit house is in the paper
so evaluation we evaluate on image net
on election air so on Alexander's low
low accuracy laws even using three
discrete value in the gradient so in
some cases believing are like observe
higher accuracy because but the large by
batch size is very large and the
variance is too small to learn well but
the variance from the conversation will
help
the exploration and here is the
convergence curve over comparing based
standard STD
so the convergence also the same and
that we evaluate on Google map we
observe we observe some small loss but
on average it's two percent one thing I
want to emphasize is we didn't do any
have a parameter all the habit
primitives are used from the standard
STD so we just use it we use the same
rate we use the same batch size we use
the same total epochs but we we could
get a better accuracy we if we tuned so
if have you ever tried that in the
beginning you use to turn gradually
train but in the end of example standard
training where decrease enter new it
from them after you decrease and earlier
which class the you this for this one is
not written you return to the full
processing of the gradient so we'll it's
kind of recover the original equity or
it's still get by decreasing we didn't
try exactly that way but we tried like
every 10 epochs the first relying a pox
we use 10 gram and the last one epoch we
use like full precision it it's similar
it's the same it's a it's a cursory
similar which third one it's not similar
with the world all right right
originally they try the one you set
probably that would help so that's all
about convergence and we can reduce the
communication so in practice hot and it
reduce the who can it make it faster so
here are the speed over the number which
abused in the distributed system and the
solid solid bars are the standard
floating-point of STD and shaded bars of
hours so we can we can always get speed
up
so in general
10 grand can give us a higher speed up
if the communication time occupies a
higher ratio that's that's obvious
because we reduce the communication so
in general give us a higher speed up if
we use more machines so if you use more
machine we have more communication ratio
or if our communication bandwidth is
very slow very low like we can get a
higher benefit we if we use low end and
like network like Ethernet versus
infinite depend or if we train like deep
new network which have a more hyper
parameter versus the computation so
personally I think it will give us more
benefits in an NLP problem than CNN
because NLP problem have more parameter
over computation also you can give us
more benefits if we use gGPO best
distributed system because GPU compute
faster under the communication is more
of the bottleneck on penguinese are in
production is adopted by facebook infra
and use it to reduce the communication
bottleneck in the area infra and it's
evaluated by the at ranking mode so
which have a zero tolerance or the
accuracy loss they cannot tolerate any
accuracy loss otherwise that means a lot
of money so and it is also available in
the package so this finished my first
apart to make the training faster and I
could take one question
yes yes we tested in for post moment and
and that was realized by its same enough
yes okay so why you can and why you let
me see why you can reduce a context the
gradient so much and the final equity is
still roughly the same because the
variance you have higher variance if you
keep the expectation but you increase
the variance so
so I could you move man just for a
second part of our research on making
infants faster so infants acceleration I
did a little bit more research on this
our land
so our even try to put a new network
with a chip which only support a spike
in you network and I also tried to
cluster the neurons of the Espace new
network and make a why your congestion
in the circular design be more efficient
but I wouldn't go too much detail our
only focus on to research here on spot
tip new networks by the way one of the
work was published when I was an intern
here my mentor was usual
so when people when people talk about
the sports new network usually they
refer to a new network which have a lot
of connections are removed it can
significantly reduce the storage size of
a given new network and if we can
customize the hardware for the specific
new network it we can gather they can
get a good speed up however we're not a
major speed on a general platform like
CPU or GPU this story is totally
different so here is a user sparsity and
we get like 95% of sparsity but when we
measured speed on the CPU on the GPU
this speed is very limited in many cases
when the speed up is why which means the
speed is the same so the speed is very
limited in some cases it's even worse so
why because this dispersity is
non-structured it's randomly distributed
but the hardware is very customized for
regular regular computation but the non
structured pattern just break the
regularity for Hardware parallelization
and so you'd have a very poor data
locality so it get retrieval speed up
it's a little bit better on it's better
on CPU platform so this one is the
speed-up of whispers randoms past new
network and over sparsity if they but
it's not it's not as good as the
phreatic speed up solid for example here
this part steadily is 19% but only two
times speed up because of the seminal
issue I just mentioned in the previous
four slides so and to make it more
efficient so we think we should use
structured sparsity instead
random non-structured sparsity so here
is a example to show the scalability of
structure despacio to you versus non
structure one so when I say structured
sparsity I mean lot of rows and the
columns are all 0 so we can just remove
those 0 rows and the columns and a
compress it is just a small dense
man-made man thanks with matrix so
because it's dense and it's small so it
can compute much faster so what's
structurally is first in the network so
in memes on connections or weights are
removed group back group not just one by
one so in a neural architecture
it means we remove one dense structures
like one neuron or it can be one layer
it can be one filter in the convolution
layer or it can be one hidden States in
the weak and the new networks in terms
of the perspective a weight matrix
it means structures possibility new
network means we move away it's block by
block so it can be so one group can be
one rectangle block can be one rule can
be one colon or even can be the whole
matrix so it's is pretty fun so how can
we achieve it how can we learn structure
sparsity it's simple again so the group
lasso regularization is all you need so
so colossal regularization what's
proposed and it's very effective to
learn structure to sparsity so basically
how does it work we we first split the
weights to group to a lot of groups like
here is a example we split them to two
groups and then we add two plus Oracle
addition on each group
which is basically the vector length of
the group so here is the group lasso on
those two groups then we add we add we
add all those group lasso regularization
as a one single regularization and we
add we add the equalization to our data
loss function like across entropy so we
just learn it end to end using
stochastic create descent good question
we split it depends on what kind of
structure you want to learn
so let's yes so it depends on what kind
of structure you want to learn let's say
you want to remove filters in the
convolution your network then one group
is all the weights in one theater so so
if we want to remove a wire role in the
weight matrix then one group is one row
of all the weights so it depends on what
kind of structure you want to learn so
we refer to our episode as SSL I'll use
this one a lot so they are more rigorous
proof about why group last week a
logician can learn structure to sparsity
but let's explaining iteratively so here
is the group of all the weights so it's
the vector it's a vector and when we do
gradient descent and it will be updated
by regular equations which come from the
data loss a plus on one additional
gradients this one is the additional
gradients and basically it's just the
unit vector going against the direction
of the vector so during the trainee in
war et al it relatively squeeze the size
of the vector and the eventually
if it can in the workout you pay zero so
in the world we move all the weights so
many groups can be be pushed to zeros
then we can you learn our structure to
sparsity pattern the whole cuckoo and
many home cooks yes so here is the
comparison alex net don't laugh at me
Alex net it was a state of work so but
is fair for comparison between long
structured responsibly and a structured
work so it's fair and very nice a
structured especially it means and this
random sparsity and so here structure is
paucity I mean I remove rows and columns
there are a lot of information here but
let's break it down
so bars here are speed up on CPU and a
GPU and the lands here are explicit e
across five layers and the orange color
correspond to long structured sparsity
and the green one corresponds to our
approach so you can see the power of the
green one are taller than the orange one
which means we can give vertical speed
up
because you get different positive yes
so in general and shallower general
network have a less compact because
usually you have a few earth filters
that are more like filters in the in the
deeper layer and also the features in
the deep layer are more sparks so that
you can achieve a higher sparsity in the
deeper layers yes
then you I would suggest we don't need
that much filter in the deeper layers in
that in this case that was at its number
of layers or this number yeah but the
index of the convolution convolution
magnitude so what's it what's the
meaning of the common so you know in the
figure you have four nuns
why is wait why is okay this is the
sparsity of the this one is dispositive
how many weights are removed this one is
how many rows are removed this one is
from Anna :
or this one how many rows this is one
how many columns yeah this one this one
is 2% but the accuracy are the same for
both they both posts have 2% tumors
inverse he about yeah
so for the base right when did you use
the original paper that we train the new
drone and every train not really we used
just every used air one but they the
sparsity is higher than their original
paper so this is the home Alex step and
so as I said what kind of structure we
want to learn Japan depends on how we
split the groups so here if you want to
remove layers then one group or weights
are all the weights in one layer so if
we remove one group then all the weights
so one layer can be removed yes that
means we can be two steps features and
they're important yes okay the
information can go through the short
cards so here is a experiments on sip I
think so and ResNet 32 we can reduce the
number of layered by 14 but we get the
similar accuracy there are a lot of
redundancy in the on deep new networks
and again we can generalize it to
lsdm so again what a kind of structure
we want to learn depends on how we split
the weights so we can remove like in
this case we can remove the hidden size
so all the white Whitestrips here are
the structures that associate it with
one hidden state so if we want to remove
one hidden States we have to remove all
the structure in the white strips like
here here is a sophisticate formula but
named curry so so if you want to remove
last hidden states that means we have to
remove on two rows and the four Collins
in the weight matrix in the elds
chairman so we basically group
and we group all the weights in one
group and we remove many groups then we
can reduce reduce the hidden size for
different models you have yes so it
depends on what you want what what
structure you want to remove so in this
case we have to prettify be pretty fine
say we want to remove hidden states then
we find all the weights associated with
one hidden state in that case then I
would I would just split the ways to
many small blocks let's say 8 by 8 and
let it learn then in the world learn
what kind of structure can be important
heuristics say okay I group the from
that this way that way and the
comparison he must own ResNet because
are you going to reduce the layers hmm
so I would say we we can we can put all
the structure or the regularization for
all kind of structure we want to learn
into one single lost then we can let
ladies learn but that would have more
have a parameters so in this case if you
come down for either beginning you do
not know this path structure so you
specify maybe the hidden size hidden
dimension to be one solid under you
put this nestled oh goodness don't you
know the space structure under there you
find that okay I only I can remove 200
so fat only it's 800 800 hidden doors so
will you between the model with this 800
and yours again or you will just use the
progression in CN which a fan Tony will
help further on and be fine and it won't
have a lot it's it's quite similar so we
didn't do that and also for sale and
just now I miss one part so what we mean
by removing role or and remove common
because say it's more like weights times
H times channel so I'm not really
understand what the meaning of row
wasn't really uncommon so that that
depends on the implementation of the
lower level so in general in cafe one
role basically is one 3d filter but in
that case we are going to try to squeeze
the size of the matrix we we do it in
the perspective of computation so so one
row is a filter is a channel one is a
visa is a filter and the one colin is
more more sophisticated but that's from
them yeah roll it's like removing one
channel of this unit stage rights also
you're going back to well scale yeah
okay I'm in this case like that the
white row and and so what all of them
are were PB moved yes I know
so when you remove that row in that case
it will look like this a column a row in
each of these majors it's like instead
of let's say you have 1000 dimension for
the hidden
H now you would make a nine-man 909
right yes okay yes so if you train for
ALS theorem for a size of 99 will give
the same result
okay there or there is something
specific about al-qaeda yes so I'm sorry
this one's better but I'll get it so we
what you were going to get there is
going to say that no you can't target
for a small dimension right at the bat
and instead you do this so the model has
the ability to actually find the right
structure order the smallest the maximum
sparsity you you're trying to okay so is
this a correct understanding if I say
that you're actually searching for the
right dimensions of the model you have a
method to find the right size for the
model that's what benefits you can just
parse it is well in the case it's just
like I just want to go and find the
right and yes and in dimension this is a
right way to do it that's yes that yes
and the speed is faster because in this
case this capacity is very simple you
just see that okay
I just first use very not hidden size
one solid and then that one okay
not only 980 is a good number I so I
think the occupation actually it's very
good to fine tuning or just first pick
the Oracle specific number not laity
under the train father beginning yes I
don't get that either is that look let's
go to here answer your question
so are we first we use this paste line
and you have originally 1500 hit stuck
in this hidden size and the user
approach we keep the original perplexity
but we reduce the size so we get a
significant speed up so to equal your
question can we train a smaller model
can you get the same performance so we
did the experiments here so we train the
same on a scam which have the same
hidden size but from scratch instead
train a small app from scratch but the
perplexity is much worse and turn to
prove me down there is another
method that you can reduce the size has
nothing to with sparsity it has nothing
to do with reduction reusing rows or
columns but they do seem about the
composition after they train a big
matrix so the idea is that if you were
trying to training the small models at
the beginning you will never find the
same result as if you have trained a
full big model and then do single
whether the composition and then do some
fine-tuning after that yes so this it's
the same line
yes it's similar here yes it's basically
a larger model give you more exploration
yes that's exactly what that was good
yes yes okay so basically here is just
the structure we learned it's very
regular it means you remove lot of rows
on the columns and the finally we just
the inference use this more model can
you pack it yes yes because it's record
yes that's the benefits of structured
passage so we basically just to create a
smaller our stem and we use the nonzero
weights to initialize it then we get
performance so in general LCM can reduce
the size while maintain the same
perplexity or we can we also make the
trade-off we can we can reduce the
sparsity realizations that little bit
larger model but we can reduce the
perplexity and it is better than
chaining our smaller model from scratch
we reduce the parent s to test capacity
um you mean why do we the really quite
right get the better of the fasting but
still methods reduce to the perpetrators
yes the large patrol if you use
parameters do better test yeah the
purple exit this is the benefit so I say
so okay yeah so basically you can get a
smaller model which have a higher which
our better performance so I think one
single how karna we changed its the top
out ratio because we had additional
regulation from the sparse
preequalization they don't need that
much regularization from this topic
that's the only one so 10 to the
complexity is it works I mean the green
light attitude achieved everyone is that
oh this one yeah for me we use a set up
and um we we change they are lambda R
equalization from the Angelica yeah yes
this is 10 theta
yes because it all depends a Holi to the
regularization and the other group are
tested has the prognostic year if you
can be part of a treatment capacity I'm
not sure about the conclusion okay
free computer did you test the training
capacity
yeah are they single yes even even even
for the last one they're using a smaller
model unlike extender you exactly
remembered number so but we care about
more about test so so what say that
meaning of those features that that
means the structure the pattern we learn
so white red region are zeros and the
blue dots are those two layers layer one
layer it you yeah
so here so basically um SSL can get a
better trade off in terms of performance
and the model size and we also did
experiments on we current highway
network and we start we start from this
baseline and then we use SSL just reduce
the size and we either reduce the
perplexity mmm or we end the use of
smaller mode or we can keep the
perplexity but the K they're much
smaller model so from this chain we can
say if we start from a large model then
rolled down then we can get a benefits
we can make a better trade off so so the
implication is we should start from
redundant model and specify done so so
this is how how does SSL work for very
long
model but we are also curious about how
does it work for very small compact
model so we did experiments on path
model which is a smaller model have only
2.7 million parameters and the hidden
size is only 100 in that case because
the model is very compact it's
originally very compact so we cannot say
keep the performance but reduce the size
but we can still make a good trade off
by SSL so for example we can reduce the
size less than one media by only job by
only job 2 percent of the FY score it's
a question answering on squad so this
concludes my previous research so
summary so we did research to make the
disputed training more scalable
using stochastic conversation over the
gradients and it's effective it's
effective I evaluated by Facebook's air
production so we can reduce the research
cycle and production cycle because we
make we can make the model train faster
and on spots new network we can enable
more ubiquity ins
AI on H devices like cell phone or
self-driving car or any VR devices
because the computation is very limited
and we also observe performance game if
we can start from a very large model
then who Kunda spicer fight down so
before you continue to the future
directions on the first one you said
that you believe the turn grad work
because you preserve the variant
actually you had more variance okay more
really more variance nobody else but
more variance and that more various
helped you and some even some situations
what is your honor
standing of wise force I mean what how
would you explain why this method works
better than like for example any other
method out there for exploring the the
size the correct sizes of the model why
does it work mmm why does it Walker
first is the tabular tip model user
needs of accountant so we can prove them
then them and the second reason is
comparing with its long structure one
structured pattern is efficient I want
you to specifically tell me if you have
understanding wise going and searching
in a bigger space and then putting it
down is better than just going directly
point query and what our strengths say
is that maybe we don't have a
sophisticated tool to just find the
right model or you have understanding
that searching a bigger space is much
better and then bringing down gives us
no loss because I just wanna see you
understand my understanding is if you
start from a large model you have more
on directions to explore and then the
proving process will find which which
direction is the right direction so you
have a larger space which means you have
more exploration in the parameter model
space then spacing specification is a
process of trying to find a good one
does the same concept of high variance
gradients apply here too like the fact
that you don't have some of these rows
or columns doesn't mean the gradients
are 0 and therefore you have higher
variance in the gradients images and
from the perspective of an exploration
they are similar so I'm trying to get
can I get the same message from the
first one and the second one yes the
first one is exploration in one model
space in the precision of the gradients
and the second and the second is in the
space of various model space yes so the
future future how can we go beyond my
research and what do I want to in the
future so how is my research related to
recent research so one related research
is a lottery ticket have four traits
which is the a clear based the paper
this year so a lottery ticket hypothesis
says four tens randomly initialized to
fill four new network there is a sub
Network which is a new network
they also referred as a mini ticket so
if you change this sub network from
scratch you can reach the similar
accuracy with the in Seminole number of
iterations they the only um hypothesis
the existence but we don't know how to
fund it
so so if you just randomly pick up a
random spot new network the accuracy
will be very very bad so so in our
recent research we found that SSL
possibly you can identify the sub
network at the early stage of the
training process so we show in our
experiments we've we find that doing SSL
learning process a lot of structures and
goes have a very high the SSL have very
high capacity in
the very early stage of the training
process and the doors zero structure
will never come back
so if so that means we can just remove
those useless structure and require only
remove those structures one by one and
the finally we just a converge to a
smaller and new network which probably
is the we need tickets so this one gives
us 40 about 40% of the training time
reduction for resonate on imagenet and
this paper is nominated by best very
student paper in supercomputing this
year dr. akido
processes it was in that high percentage
what they found is if they fund us space
structure and then they trained us then
the treatise paths are specific as an
organism China's vast network then the
equity will be recovered
but in your case in fact you are arguing
if you haven't that's specifically
Oracle if and they just treat from the
beginning you cannot reach this thing
they will of accuracy because you lose
the exploration and power of Perseus
will know very much space space under
the fan and gradually go to this fast
pattern no actually no sorry
allowed me to get story is that you can
be covered good accuracy this phone
network if you start with the same
initial ization yes as you did before
you crewman and this is a way of
preserving that residue of the
initialization after proving as well
this is old does that mean
they enjoy German in the in your
summarizations nights in the nos police
what do you say that it's better to
start from a tennis not Network and then
use s AOL to use SSL to cannot you find
the Espace network that one give you
higher basic tasks so you try that if
you are directly given the Espace
structure and design to for the
beginning you cannot reach the same
equity but have you ever tried just next
a lottery ticket hypothesis just
remember your initial Ventus
initialization and then use the same
random initialization and to to tune the
space model mmm so exactly we can I'm
with you the lottery
yes hypothesis yes yes so that means we
can use SSL to identify the rainy
tickets so that's the relationship here
so hungry paper in the paper they just
tell exploration on non-structured
specially pattern this one is like so so
we are we are thinking probably SSL care
and 25 the winning tickets it's also
identify a structure with me yes yes
exactly
but however Bernie can remember the
brand initialization of the century with
the specific not yet it's an open
question there but that finger we were
to try that's you should but no way you
can get that random I mean I think you
that experiment shows you is get the
same reserve so what I mean is I want to
understand what's the connection between
Sao SSA or under the authoritarian
hypothesis whether they are the same
thing all their different hmm yes
that's very interesting future research
so the second related work to my
previous research is auto ml so an
automated machinery to use a machine to
design a machine in the model so when we
when the community make a lot of
progress on a thermal the fact that it's
much more efficient to do in this way
so they design a very large model which
have all the operation options enabled
in this single one short model decoite
one-shot model because they have all
options enabled and the goal is to pick
up an optimal path and it's so the
experiments show this method is very
efficient for optimal but so the
question is can we use SSL for thermal
so in SSL basically trying to remove
structures so a second open question is
can we use SSL for automail so another
research direction inspired by my
previous research is on scaling and
nopee problem so going back to my
statement at the very beginning to kind
of change change of deep learning is if
we can chain a large model we can always
get a better performance this is even
more true in NLP for unsupervised
learning
so here is the ablation study for the
pert and if we can they didn't train in
a large model to get a better
performance but personally I think and
notice in the widget in Adira and it's
very hard to further scale up because of
the computation the memory cost so we
need a more scalable training master
than the most scalable best models to
scale up so one direction we can go is
we design more skill approach any metric
so basically it means given or
architecture let's say pert
can we make it the training faster so we
could use ten grand SSL but what's more
mm-hmm doesn't make training person say
it again
SSL does not make training faster you
can get that information yeah but you
still have to have the entire
architecture to reduce it otherwise
unless you reduce it in the training we
we just the same the checkpoint and they
create a new smaller one
oh okay thank you reduce the size but if
you want to truly go in the original
model and you want to find it you still
have to keep the original size yes
horrible but our experiments you'll zero
architecture never come back really
rarely come back so we just removed and
training some other one graduate okay
yeah
so the second direction cities are more
scalable new models so we should design
or faster accurate and the sorry tap
here compact best model and scale up so
and I also believe that automail will
play a very important role in designing
compact small and no people models so
this brings me to this another future
research I would want you on automail so
this figure also equals to my previous
statement this is the computer vision
models and in recent years people
generally design more scalable model so
the smaller with smaller model but
higher accuracy designs most Kalama
model and scale up so this model is
designed by automail it's not vacuuming
so I believe automail will be very
important in design compact NLP models
in the future but there are two problems
in automail the first problem is optimal
its CPU each GPU its memory its
everything so it's very inefficient the
second problem is polymer relies on
human designed operations and only
search they
combinations it cannot event any like
new architectures that's the problem of
autumn L so in the past in the past half
years and I did some research on the
first problem and to make the sample
more efficiency so the x-axis is the
number of a network we have to chain to
reach some test accuracy so this one is
a random method this one is the
state-of-art
regular is the evolution and my recent
research is getting here
so now we can chain we can find the best
and Oracle and model within hundreds of
samples which means we have to only
train with hundreds of network to find
the optimal and we'll make it public in
next month and the way that conclude my
talk and I'll bring open to questions
[Applause]
that's a question with tiny quick so
apparently you transmit two bits for
every gradient but you only get to use
three buckets yes we missed one that's
right so what about efficient way to use
four bits - yes that yes yes so if we
use two peas in a real production we
definitely should use four levels we
want we don't want to waste it but
that's that's the research you have more
interested in like how can we really
aggressively to reduce the precision so
in that paper we use the three levels
but in like production the they were I
mentioned we they used eight bits so
that's that's the trade-off
okay so let's say I want to apply as
well to transformers suggestions okay
side ropes right just as you did for SIA
and saying I want designs and growth for
transformers and my goal is my goal can
be what I want to get some interpreting
interpretation sorry it yes and the
second one is I want to reduce the
computation of speed up I know that this
could be different goals and can you say
something that how I can design groups
so that I can't achieve these goals
simultaneously or no nothing and same
against working hard so so for the to
reduce the sizeable model so let's say
we can use it to reduce the hidden size
of the network or we can reduce the
amount of like heads so that that's
basically how we split the groups for
the for the first
on the interpretability so usually we
say simpler model is more interpretable
so if we use ssl we reduce the size of
the model then that would be more
interpret different well why does this
transformation what interesting thing is
the mechanism right okay if I cannot
find sparsity j2 transformers si if I
can get something like for the given
total this token attend attend only a
few other lot of you other tokens in a
sentence this could be something
interesting then I think we can use a
mask mask parameter to mask the
attention and then recognize the
irregularity and it will if if the
corresponding weights in the Max is zero
that means that attention is useless we
can learn the mask yes
but I think in the current average the
mosque pretty fine
oh I mean I'm not know that mask I mean
the mask over the whole pitch and that's
the parameter that's American family we
can
bettan is I think the boss was a
versatile marketer podcast all the birth
of his grandmother's basically the Train
tribute are super with passion and 9000
shouldn't ask
thank you a thousand customers model
encourage every remove some components
should be easier because if he removes
for some consequence just somewhere is
not important but maybe it was a
compress your third model into the
general model but small motors still
have you were catalyzing when cars are
you the parent is so for the own stupid
I mean people usually use a language
modeling yeah so I have so the
effectiveness of Assessor own and
language modeling and that's one thing
another thing is we can separate this
specification for unsupervised learning
and the for specific tasks so two very
specific tasks we can specify the new
parameter for specific tasks
personalized learning model is Li you
you still tense or same task read the
study you you after you compress that
model and fight you your this language
model to add your other tasks
no sort of literature right but for
example the biggest thing we've seen in
terms of shrinking some labor is Albert
where the way it's done is that you end
up with parameter sharing how would how
would i how would I catch the first of
all there's I guess there's a couple of
questions one is like we probably don't
have the right architectures in the
first place but the latest that is we
may not have the right sort of set of
actions to put into your framework so
for example can I put into an auto ml
framework oh yeah you should be
searching over all possible sets of
parameters that should be shared and not
actually duplicated for the money right
or like or what sort of what are the
kind of limits here because we just sort
of don't actually even know what the
building blocks are that we should be
yes yes that's that's the second problem
I mentioned yes autumn L it cannot event
any like new architecture mmm so I think
and we could be but the search space
will be very large so it will take very
long turn long long time so for example
what can we learn a convolution you'd
blow new network from a fully connecting
new network mmm theoretically yes but
the search space is just a too large so
I think that would be the trade-off
between how we bridge that so in the
sense that like if you know is there a
way that you thought of mail to
basically say like hey you know hey Hugh
and please help me out a little bit like
I mean I'm sort of I'm seeing some
sparsity over here maybe it's nothing
maybe you know maybe it maybe there's
something here and then you could go in
and you do this as a more iterative
fashion I think the thing that bothers
me about the formulation both for the
Star Trek Star City and for auto ml is
this sort of notion that we already have
already created the right basic
architectures because I just don't buy
that assumption in the first place right
I think all of our models are probably
very wrong so it's great that we can
make them better but then is there a way
to sort of extend the framework so that
you have sort of a more iterative
process of improving these things er yes
and so one suggestion is we can view the
automail framework but we human can
propose some like new architecture we
added into the search space and automail
will automatically define where should
you put the new architecture so in that
sense ultima will help but I think
automail and the human spirits walk well
I mean if they work together it will get
much more benefits
nothingness that always be okay
[Applause]